hello and thank you very much for your
time and the opportunity today today i
will go over some very specific examples
of how plant-breeding teams bring value
to the florida culture industry we will
start our story with the general value
of adding new species to cultivation
and move
from the past to the future of new
speech introduction my intention here is
not to drill down on the specifics of
techniques used but rather to illustrate
some of these how these tools are used
and will continue to add value from the
perspective of new crop introductions
an avid gardener and seeds man thomas
jefferson said the greatest service
which can be rendered any country is to
add useful plants to its culture and
useful plants we've added some people
estimate that the total number of
species cultivated globally is around 35
000.
if you look
at species grown for food the fao
suggests that 52 of those account for
most of the world's calories and if you
take that 80 20 analysis even further
three species rice maize and wheat
account for sixty percent of our
calories
the last decades have seen a steady
decrease in the number of species
cultivated for food and fiber
however there has been a steady increase
in the number of species cultivated
ornamentally
it's not unheard of
for large suppliers in the florida
culture industry to deal in more than a
thousand genera across all products
available when you think about it it's
an incredible incredible amount of plant
diversity actively managed by some
organizations just imagine being the
stocks in manager on one of those farms
the majority of food and fibre species
were domesticated thousands of years ago
and new species with real impact on the
market is unusual canary grass was
approved for human consumption by the
fda in 2016 but however i doubt that it
will have a large impact on the global
global cereal industry
in the left side of the slide is a photo
of losiantes it's a u.s native and was
first introduced to the japanese market
in 1933 it made its way over to the u.s
in 1980s today liziantes is one of the
world's leading cut flowers on the top
right is an image of impatience while
rihanna
in patients while rihanna is native to
southeastern parts of africa initial
breeding efforts started in the 1940s
with serious efforts in the 1950s by
claudio in costa rica
by the 1990s impatient or busy lizzies
were one of the top selling bidding
plants globally early reports of
impatient animals came out in the early
2000s and by 2012 the global impatient
market was devastated by the animal due
fortunately there were other species for
growers to prove to provide we will come
back to impatience a little later
lastly we can look at the example of
calibrachoa calibrachoa came from the
wild and was introduced in japan in the
late 1980s and made it to the us by
1994.
very quickly calibracho was domesticated
and today calibrachoa is one of the
leading vegetatively propagated batting
plants these examples are to impress
upon you the relevance of adding new
species to cultivation in the
floriculture industry
to be clear i want to make sure that
these examples are in no way i'm trying
to detract from the incredible
achievements in breeding by my
counterparts working in food and fiber
crops especially those working in canary
grass the difference however lies in the
market needs with regards to novel
phenotypes for floriculture and
agronomic crops
before we continue this discussion
we have to define what a species is so
let us define a plant species as the
largest group of plants in which two
individuals can sexually reproduce
this definition is brought by design i
realized that in some of the examples i
will present that meiosis may not be
perfect but this however should not be a
hurdle to our discussion
so where did species come from
traditionally traditionally species came
to cultivation from explorers and
collectors taking samples and bringing
them back to their countries or
organizations
explorers like david fairchild in the
top right or parliament dorset on the
left
added a tremendous amount of diversity
to the usda for example fairchild and
his colleagues added over 80 000
accessions to the usda and dorset
over 4 000 soybean excisions
for various reasons it is becoming
increasingly challenging to find new
species to domesticate for one very
little of our world remains unexplored
secondly there are significant
administrative
hurdles for geoplasma collection trips
if agreements
between a group of a foreign country and
authorities can be
reached there may not always be enough
trust equity in local communities to
share with collectors
although unfortunate
purely from a breaches perspective these
challenges does not mean the end of the
road for new species introductions
when we look at success from new species
introduction in the recent past one
finds clues to indicate where future
success may come from
modern plant breeders are part of teams
working to bring useful plants to
culture today's breeding teams may have
few or no individuals like fairchild or
endorse it but often have major
contributing members with specific
skills in in vitro biology
from here i will go over some specific
examples of in vitro tools used and
impactful products resulting from
deploying these tools
along with chromosome doubling embryo
rescue is one of the most commonly used
in vitro techniques in creating new
species
for clarity when i refer to immunorescue
i also refer to ovule culture
ornamental plant breeders attempt wide
interspecific and indigenery crosses
regularly without access to efficient
embryo rescue protocols an even lower
number of these white crosses will be
successful
white crosses often result in sterile
hybrids like the specific kofi are shown
in the bottom left powder we will not
refer to this scuffy as a species yet
in staying with the example from the
interspecific kofi from the previous
page the breeder may want to have the in
the pacific kufia doubled the chromosome
number double and hopefully restore
fertility so chromosing doubling using
spindle poisons like colchicine in
orzellin are commonplace activities and
critical to the goal of bringing new
species to the market
although not always successful some of
the results could be striking as can be
seen in the example of the significant
flower size increase in going from the
diploid to the tetraploid level for both
salvia and lobularia so apart from
counting chromosomes and looking at dna
content one can look at stoneman guard
cells and they can be very good
predictors of ploidy
other than doubling the sterile hybrid
another common application may be to
create auto polyploids of species the
breeder is looking to cross and attempt
interspecific or even intergeneric
crosses using the same species on
different ploidy levels
access to the right germplasm is at the
key moment is critical in any breeding
operation working with various species
often with varying degree of fertility
or short seed shelf life breeders also
make use of tissue cultures for
germplasm preservation
we have to talk about some tools less
commonly used
it should come without saying that there
are many other tools
than in in vitro tools and embryo risky
and grain wisdom doubling a major
limiting factor in applying some of
these other techniques listed here are
good protocols that are not cultivar
dependent a quick search through
literature will allow you to find
horiculture products sometime new
species created using
some or all of the techniques on the
left
my personal wishlist has been for years
to have been have access to more
protoplast regeneration protocols and
haploid inductions
sometimes it would be great to reduce
the body levels and high ploidy crops
like pansies
personally i would love the opportunity
to develop a deployed painting similar
to efforts in developing deployed
potatoes
the field of in vitro research has been
around for a while but have gone out of
favor in the last three decades
fortunately for technologies like gene
editing often requiring protoplast
regeneration protocols there may be more
students trained in these techniques in
the next coming years
as we're moving towards the back end of
the talk we're switching gears now to
give specific examples of how new
species have created had significant
impact on the market the xenia elegance
has fantastically beautiful colors but
suffers from severe powdery module in
some regions
dunya angostifolia
does not suffer from those but do have
very limited color range
leaders from the university of maryland
made them specific hybrids
and created a
fertile
alloy tetraploid the name zinnia
marylandica was established and
published in 1991. senior marylandica
combines very well both the heat
tolerance and powdery moldy resistance
with the striking color range not all
zenia elegance colors are available yet
in the marylandica but the new species
have been very successful and i can
assure you that several companies have
breeding programs in this space
but juniors have been a popular batting
plant all for well over a hundred years
earlier i introduce you to calibrachoa
gala ricoa is a relative and in the same
family
and has a fantastic color range and
similar other positive aspects
readers have been able to successfully
make intergeneric hybrids between the
two combining several of the benefits
from both species into a single product
it is also possible and it happens that
the least desired traits of a species
can be combined
the intrageneric hybrids shown here are
sterile and thus according
to our definition not the species yet
but the broad color range already in the
market it is not a large stretch of the
imagination that this in the generic
hybrid could one day be turned into
designer new species just look at all
the
colors that i pulled from
online catalog
so we briefly mentioned impatience
valerian earlier
and patience is a large genus with
hundreds of species
on the left i'm showing part of breeding
history from a patent for interspecific
sun tolerant inpatient this clearly
shows the making of interspecific
hybrids using embryo rescue very likely
chromosome
doubling to restore fertility and making
further crosses the result the resulting
product had been very successful on the
market
earlier i mentioned how impatience while
rihanna market was devastated by
impatience down in mildew fittingly
readers are going back to some of the in
vitro tools to allow them access to
downing multi-resistance from species
other than valeriana and in the process
maybe creating new species
so although i certainly hope that we
will continue to domesticate new species
from the wild i believe that breeding
teams will create designer new species
combining the best of two or sometimes
more species
in vitro tools are great enabling
technologies and i trust that it would
be clear to some of the younger members
of the audience that specializing in in
vitro techniques as they are related to
plant breeding can bring a colorful
career opportunities helping to bring
beautiful plants to our culture thank
you very much